this reporter asks real questions
william kelly joins us tonight
it's wonderful to be with you this is a
textbook first amendment case
unfortunately uh the textbook is from
venezuela
right
look it looks i mean are we missing
something i mean you are not your
credentials were revoked because you
asked the most obvious possible question
are cities falling apart what are you
going to do and then no longer allowed
exactly right i believe that journalism
is extremely important i've had a media
credential in chicago for over 10 years
emmy award-winning
print radio tv
but mayor lightfoot is the least
transparent mayor in our city's history
and
sadly
my uh
for better or for worse the reason my
questions were so effective is because i
was asking the questions that real
chicagoans wanted to hear but they were
hurting her re-election campaign so she
canceled my media credential i think the
real
scandal here tucker is that the mayor
lightfoot has 80 plus security guards
that are assigned to protect her from me
asking her questions during a
re-election campaign at a time when the
chicago police are down 1500 officers
crime is out of control there's
record low arrests and a spike in police
suicides it's my prayer that a federal
judge will restore my media credential
tomorrow so i can go back to chicago
city hall and ask about the spike in
police suicide which is
such a tragedy that's facing our city
right now
i mean this is obvious censorship really
quick have other media organizations
chicago tribune for example have they
filed complaints with the mayor's office
on your behalf have they stood with you
in solidarity
i think that this has had a chilling
effect on all reporters they see
that i asked real questions and i got my
credential
revoked uh cancelled i guess would be a
better word you know i grew up in
chicago watching uh legendary reporters
pam zachman john bulldog drummond
chasing
politicians up and down the street right
and uh and this is the tradition i want
to uphold this is the chicago reporter
tradition that lightfoot wants to cancel
yeah i mean mike royko would be so
ashamed of what's happened to your city
and its media i appreciate mr kelly
thank you for coming on tonight
thank you tucker
subscribe to the fox news youtube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from tucker carlson
tonight